the deadly shooting raises new questions
about school and government officials
efforts to keep students safe 33 states
including Florida require every school
or school district to have a
comprehensive safety or emergency plan
Adriana Diaz is at Stoneman Douglas High
School in parkland that you're on a good
morning good morning in a cruel twist
the school was reportedly planning an
active shooter drill in just a few weeks
but it's unclear if any planning or
preparation could have stopped the
gunman all entrances at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School are locked during
the school day reopening when students
leave that's when police say the
suspected gunman set off a fire alarm
and then opened fire
in school drills like this our common
nationwide to prepare for active shooter
situation teachers at Stoneman Douglas
were trained on what to do with such an
event but while some students report
going through an active shooter drill at
the school others received less training
we did have meetings with our teachers
about where we need to go what we should
do in these situations but we never had
an active shooter drill a lockdown was
effective in keeping a shooter out of a
California school last year because
officials had advanced notice he was
approaching
but the same plan in Florida Wednesday
turned chaotic because there was no such
notice and the accused shooter set off a
fire alarm sending students rushing out
of their classrooms when the gunman was
already on campus former police officer
Adam Caron teaches students how to deal
with active shooter scenarios the
situation is very fluid so to say that
you have a one-size-fits-all model for a
dynamic situation may not be the total
solution
he says training is important but it may
be impossible to keep students 100% safe
if somebody really wanted to get into
the school with this malicious intent
they could have no matter what and I
don't think any security feature really
could have prevented that other than a
prison the school locks its doors during
the school day but they do not have
metal detectors and the expert we spoke
to said that a lockdown could be the
safest scenario in some school shootings
but not all Gayle Adrianna thank you
very much